comment vous avez été recruté en moi en
fait c'est une longue histoire quand en
fait c'est 8 m'appelez pas des huit à
l'époque rappelle pour faire nommer les
stars ils me disent il faudra faire
touche pas à mon poste et par orgueil je
voulais dire expliqué j'ai dit ça jamais
jamais donc j'ai perdu du temps parce
que j'ai fait donc sur nouvelle star et
j'étais très bien lancé chaque semaine
par séries avec un garde est en fait
j'ai perdu du temps et c'est vrai qu'on
était on était potes sans plus avec
cyril j'ai été faire un tour nrj 12 est
trop petit tour et puis je donc
retrouver sans rien et cyril m'a rappelé
et c'est en ça que c'est plutôt agréable
qui m'a rappelé monde et voilà j'ai un
jeu que camil devait faire kim a tout
dit magalie vaé t on rejoint nous fait
touche pas à mon poste
et voilà je suis très heureux parce
qu'en plus d'avoir gagné une émission
j'ai gagné un ami voilà benjamin il
restera avec nous sur ces vite jusqu'à
jusqu'au bout je suis sûr il nous
lâchera plus 1 pourquoi pas les
médailles malheur vous c'est l'autre
histoire c'est tout autre chose en fait
je suis venu pour faire de la promo pour
un conte pour enfants au théâtre des
variétés
l'écolo et écolo exactement et pour une
émission sur tv5 monde
et puis pendant l'émission ça c'est
hyper bien passé et comme vous avez
parfois l'habitude de le faire quand ça
se passe bien on m'avait dit ça vous
dirait d'intégrer la bande pendant
l'émission à l'antenne en direct et j'ai
dit oui et après je vous ai dit gratuite
moi j'ai pas entendu et quelques jours
après on m'a appelé puis je suis venu
pour un pour une première et puis une
deuxième et puis et bas ou séries je me
rappelle nous avait rejoints lors de la
première saison de tpm p sur ces 8 alors
que j'ai bien sûr vos premiers à tous
les deux à tous les deux à tous les deux
non mais ce que je lui connais bien
c'est bien mais il avait une très belle
poitrine au regard des benjamins ii bat
enfin sa main est ce que tu es content
d'être avec nous forger très j'étais un
peu l'eau un peu la tente mais c'est
bien je compte mais c'est toujours comme
ça c'est ça avec moi c'est toujours ya
beaucoup d'attentes
non mais sérieux benjamin c'est vrai que
on va pas se mentir ça a étonné plein de
gens que tu nous rejoignent en vain - tu
sais quoi moi le premier je sais mais
comme disait
quand même comme disait sheryfa luna il
avait les mots madame 1 et et valérie
bénaïm on va regarder ce que les
abeilles dit lors de votre arrivée
regardez il est franco colombien se
reporter donc effectivement quand il va
sur le terrain ils parlent espagnol
il connaît pas ce que c'est à 1800 km la
colombie ce n'est pas bien loin et donc
effet que si ce n'est pas parce que je
vois c'est votre première émission vous
avez vu bon là on a des noms on a un
gars on connaît sa nationalité
non c'est vrai et valérie il savait
n'est pas trop évolué depuis le début
parce que regarder c'était sa city ont
mis en début moi j'étais en 2010 à
nantes et en 2012 2012 2012
regardez regarde on a fait un morphing
valérie bénaïm regarder aux gardes et
valérie bénaïm 2è saurions le dire est
qu'elle est précis est pas mal
vous allez voir que ça va être beaucoup
plus violent avec jean michel jean
michel maire vous comment vous la mettez
recruter abbas et un coup du destin
incroyable j'étais aux filières à
l'époque j'étais chroniqueur sur une
chaîne qui n'existe plus l'appeler de
tps star
il ya beaucoup de chaînes quand vous
passez bétaillère voilà c'était une
émission ce média un peu sérieuse qui se
voulait sérieuse et il se trouve que
j'avais démissionné du figaro et donc du
coup je démissionnais lucie bisson parce
que c'est un club de la presse n'avait
plus rien à y faire et il trouve que
coup du sort le dernier invité de cette
émission là c'est vous incroyable et du
coup l'émission se termine je remets ma
vie invité parce qu'en fait je pense y
avait quelqu'un qui s'était désisté oui
je le sais pas moi ce n'est pas moi
l'animateur s'était julie raynaud julie
raynaud et que c'était une amie et donc
l m'adapter presque vos exact voilà
sinon rien partiez au moment de partir
chaque arme et son blouson et vous
partez et on est bon à la prochaine la
prochaine mais sans moi parce que moi
c'est ma dernière mission et vous ne
dites pas pourquoi de ces dernières qui
pas parce que j'ai démissionné le figaro
donc j'ai plus rien à faire ici jiabao
khaimah une autre fois ailleurs il vous
repartez vous arrêter lorsqu'il est
toute ma vie vous retournez vous dit bah
tiens j'y pense tu vas faire quoi après
juba où je ne sais pas il ya un casting
jeudi prochain si ça t'amuse n'a rien à
faire passe et je suis allé au casting
jaur et épices à ce moment là j'étais
pas là il se trouve que heureusement
chaque chose c'est dommage je vais
percer chacun d'eux une chronique
c'était samuel etienne qui faisait le de
l'animateur d'inviter le faux amis
c'était un pilote qui n'était pas
diffusée et il y avait plein de bons
basten jolie fille j'étais persuadé pas
être pris et ma deuxième chance etc avec
yannick bolloré qui était acté notre ami
et associé et je le connais c'est parce
que comme je travaille au service télé
du figaro j'avais rencontré faire des
interviews puis je crois qu'il m'aimait
bien il est bien il m'aimait bien aller
pour la dialectique lundi un petit mot
sur à vous et je crois que c'est ça qui
a fait que ben ouais autrement je pense
que jamais vous auriez embauché donc
merci yannick gervais seul à le
remercier parce que c'est lui qui m'a
craché dessus moi moi je vous dis la
vérité c'est que vous aviez fait un
papier sur moi sur hanouna plage dans le
figaro j'avais fait l'émission encore
dans les campings ouais et vous avez été
moi je me rappelle on m'avait dit tu vas
rencontrer jean michel maire fait
attention c'est un intello
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas une paille du coup je vous
jure que là c'est la vérité ni moi j'ai
discuté avec des patrons de radio qui
m'ont dit à l'époque jean michel maire
faisait peur à tout le monde il ya
vraiment si tu vas rencontrer jean
michel maire fait attention c'est un
ponte du journalisme c'est dans le c'est
lui qui fait la pluie le beau temps au
figaro sur la télé donc je le dis il
faut que tu sois très bon et ont gelé
rencontrés alors je n'essaie pas du tout
jean michel maire nous quand ils étaient
ils étaient hyper sérieux c'est déjà lui
mais un slip et où je me suis non mais
et je vous jure que c'est vrai et donc
j'ai fait des interviews avec lui et il
a été super sympa dans le papier c'est
vrai vous avez fait un très net repli
sur soi voilà et derrière c'est vrai que
on associer m'avait dit jean michel
maire est un excellent journaliste je
pense qu'il le faudrait victoire en plus
ça va vraiment élever le niveau et les
missions
[Rires]
c'est comme si c'est comme si vous
engagez quelqu'un parce que c'est un bon
avant centre en fait il est gardien
c'est un peu ça commence un peu saturé
moreau et la m'attendais à voir aboutir
et mme banon parce que j'ai quand même
ce qu'on voudra plaie de la première
phrase que vous avez dit bonjour
non mais vous rappelle que vous aviez
diaboliser ou par action à jamais une
tête aux riches ne me faire greffer les
cheveux j'avais des poireaux soit déjà à
l'époque une première grave caméra c est
là bas je à points ont fait oublier le
cheveu théorie de regarder avec mais
également jean michel maire on peut bien
avec ce qu'ils gagnent ça va merci là
quelque chose qui est choquant quand on
regarde les images comme ça c'est que
les moniales c'est aussi une voix c'est
que dès que ça commence maintenant la
voie est maintenant on peut fermer les
yeux on voit les images c'est absolument
incroyable
l'animateur qu'on ne voit aussi
pertinente aussi reconnaissable il a il
a la joie et les choses c'est plus que
mathieu et c'est bien c'est du non non
non là il était nu rhin sans rigoler et
frère fêter le soldat les veaux qui
commence ici mon frère je veux commencer
il commence en daguste des cheveux mais
de d'arrière mettez beaucoup plus beau
maintenant oui mais regarde et on évolue
[Rires]
oui c'est lui isabelle ça fait plusieurs
saisons que vous faites partie de la
bande
voilà on adore vos anecdotes elles sont
devenues légendaires maintenant les
connais un petit peu par coeur et on les
aime comme ça est ce que vous vous
rappelez
comme vous avez été recruté ou oui moi
aussi j'étais petite femme et moi je
vous connaissais de rtl ouais et moi je
vous suivez dans les émissions que vous
adorez dans le grand concours on l'a
fait plusieurs fois ensemble si vous
avez gagné par mois et c'était moi je
vous ai toujours vraiment admiré en tant
qu'animateur y compris comment vous et
le bêtisier ah ouais quand même mois
bassi parce que vous aviez justement une
façon de personnaliser le truc et vous
m'avez dit à rtl tient un jour on
bossera ensemble et vous m'avez dit ce
que tu serais d'accord pour nous
rejoindre je dis oui
puis après vous avez croisé dans la rue
quand l'émission s'est monté vous me dit
est ce que vous pouvez toujours d'accord
pour nous rejoindre je dis oui qu'après
plus de plus d'appels du tout comme vous
aviez plein de gens brillants je me suis
dit bon bah il a oublié un comme moi je
pense pas que le monde m'attend et 1re
manche et mais qu est ce qu il voulait
absolument je bosse avec lui et lui ils
étaient tous les jours devant elle en me
disant rejoins-nous sur les réseaux
sociaux comme tu es nul ça va être drôle
et finalement je suis allé à france 4
avec lui quand vous vous en étiez parti
vous m'avez dit ce qu'ils savaient qu
elles ne viendront jamais dans l'émotion
à cauet qui présentait l'émission
non c'est pas lui provisoire fg trône
alaouite et puis vous avez dit me
viendrait jamais dans l'émission puisque
la justice jusqu'à présent vous avez une
défection et quelqu'un m'a appelé en
disant ce que tu serais d'accord
l'objectif de venir
égérie ben moi oui moi j'adore toujours
cyril donc et c'est comme ça que ça a
commencé je vous ai plus lâches et aviez
besoin d'une gamme donc non c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai regardez une petite
compil d'isabelle morini-bosc regarder
une à une à côté alors je peux vous dire
est à la tête parce que c'est vrai mine
de rien c'est le magazine le plus tiré
après jour patrick le futur michael bay
non mais c'est vrai et oui physiquement
puisque moi ça c'est sûr ça comment oui
alors isabelle chien boullier regardez
isabelle n'a pas changé on a fait le
mort si sûr isabelle la passion des
liens et corinne charby là c'est la même
c'est la même chose vous n'avez pas
toujours dit on regarde tout de suite
votre première phrase dans l'émission
très très content qu'il rejoint l'équipe
de touche pas à mon poste
applaudissements pour jean luc lemoine
et voilà petit truc déjà pour vous jean
luc lemoine était mon ex on est sortis
ensemble de 86 à 88
voilà il faut que les gens que ça c'est
très bien de tout balancer tout de suite
un peu de mystère
aujourd'hui on a fait une petite
réplique de jean luc lemoine sur france
regardez au lieu que moi actuellement je
suis dans touche pas à mon poste
est ce que j'ai à trouver un vrai boulot
j'en ai vous soutenez ki moon moi
j'étais pour johnny ballon dégoûté mais
pour le talent pour le nom danger pour
tous j'ai envie de chialer parce que
vous insultez pas mais surtout je trouve
juste un petit coucou à justine et je
trouve ça très élégant de pas voir dick
avait une gastro
[Rires]
jean luc lemoine
alors je lui on attend le film hors fils
de jean-luc regarder et jean-luc regard
d'eva joly va les fatiguer attirer les
mieux mieux de mieux en mieux de bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je rappelle ya vu un sondage à l'époque
quand il était dans on a tout essayé
non on n'est pas couché on n'est pas
couché et il avait fait un sondage pour
savoir qui était le chroniqueur le plus
beau gosse de la télé et c'est jean-luc
avait dit la vérité
jean-luc j'étais arrivé premier mon ami
cyril hanouna
c est foutu de ma gueule parce qu'il
comprenait pas le délire il faut savoir
que le numéro 2 c'était nicolas
canteloup ouais bon je pense que se
savait rien d'avoir cotisé
oui parce que mélanger très bon niveau
les leurs à 6,6 bah tu veux tu peux pas
me dire ça c'est sûr ça m'a fait rêver
une fatigue je passe à chaque fois
s'amener sur l'ascenseur émotionnel de
dégueulasse à correct je t'ai jamais
trouvé dégueulasse
alors aujourd'hui je peux que juste pour
voilà pourquoi vous rappeler toujours
cette anecdote du fait que j'avais été
plus beaux gosses des chroniqueurs même
si c'était une surprise pas de rappeler
juste qu'il est beau gosse et si on
refaisait un sondage ce sera encore lui
isabelle drault pas n'en appelle pas
longtemps moi je suis très sexy et dès
le début il est très beau oui